coronavirus cases fueled by the delta
variant continue to surge primarily
among the unvaccinated as the fda
authorizes booster shots for some people
and more employers are requiring
vaccination as a condition for returning
to work
joining us now to discuss the latest
guidance the director of the national
institutes of health dr francis collins
dr collins let's start with the latest
figures on this fourth
wave of the coronavirus i want to put
the stats up on the screen the latest
average of new cases is more than 129
000 new cases a day that's up more than
700 percent
from the beginning of july assuming
current trends of the spread of the
virus and assuming the current level of
vaccinations
how high could this wave get before a
crest how many new cases could we be
seeing a day
well chris we can't really predict that
all we can say is that this is going
very steeply upward with no signs of
having peaked out so i will be surprised
if we don't cross 200 000 cases a day in
the next couple of weeks and that's
heartbreaking considering we never
thought we would be back in that space
again
that was january february that shouldn't
be august but here we are with delta
variant which is so contagious and this
heartbreaking situation where 90 million
people are still unvaccinated who are
sitting ducks for this virus and that's
the mess we're in we're in a world of
hurt and it's a critical juncture to try
to do everything we can to turn that
around
we are also seeing a sharp rise in the
number of pediatric cases both
unvaccinated kids and vaccinated kids
who are getting coveted from this new
delta variant how bad
could that spike in pediatric cases get
that's very worrisome i think
traditionally people kind of considered
well you know kids aren't going to get
that sick with this more than 400
children have died of covet 19 and right
now we have almost 2 000 kids in the
hospital many of them in icu some of
them under the age of four so anybody
tries to tell you well don't worry about
the kids the virus won't really bother
them that's not the evidence and
especially with delta being so
contagious kids are very seriously at
risk and it's up to all of us to do
everything we can to protect them as
well as we're trying to protect
everybody else at the same time
you talk about protecting them seven
states across the country have bans in
place bans against
mandates for school
mass mass for these kids when they're in
the school and florida governor ron
desantis is leading the charge here he
was this week sir
if you're coming after the rights of
parents in florida i'm standing in your
way i'm not going to let you get away
with it
how strong is the case that children in
school
should wear masks as a mitigation
against delta
chris it's very strong
go to the cdc website you'll see more
than a dozen publications showing that
evidence and already you can see in this
country the schools that have started to
open without mask requirements outbreaks
are happening and what happens then the
kids are sent home for virtual learning
which is what we were trying to avoid
it's really unfortunate that politics
and polarization have got in the way of
a simple public health measure this mask
that i'm holding has somehow become a
symbol that it never should have been
this is basically just a life-saving
medical device
and somehow it's now being seen as an
invasion of your personal liberty we
never should have gone there it's
heartbreaking for me as a person who's
not a politician i'm a scientist i'm a
public health person i'm a doctor to see
how mass have gotten into this very
strange place with parents and
others shouting about it we never should
allow that to happen
i i want to pick up on that because the
board of education
in williamson county tennessee near
nashville held a meeting this week on
the issue of mass mandates and there
were some parents in the group including
some some doctors who had kids in the
school who were urging
that everybody wear masks that there be
a mask mandate and i want to play the
the reaction the scene in the parking
lot after the meeting of the school
board here they are
we know we know who you are we know who
you are
as
the head of the national institutes
of health as a person who's devoted your
life to public health
what's your reaction sir when you see
that
well it's devastating that we in this
country the most advanced technological
society on the planet has somehow
slipped into a space
where the evidence and the basis for
making decisions on facts has gotten
pushed aside by politics by social media
conspiracies and by this incredible
depth of anger and grievance that seems
to be held by so many
our future as a nation has got to
revolve around coming away from that
kind of approach to everything or i
don't see how we're going to solve all
of our society's problems which are
looming in front of us
if i have one thing i'm worried about
it's not just the epidemic of covet 19
it's the epidemic of misinformation
disinformation distrust that is tearing
us apart
one of the big questions now dr collins
is whether or not all of us who got the
vaccines in the first place are going to
need a third shot or a booster whatever
you want to call it because of declining
protection from the vaccine
over time now you and the cdc and all
the top government scientists are saying
well maybe sometime later this fall
maybe early next year
but in israel right now they are giving
the third shots to everybody over 60 and
starting this week they're going to be
giving the shot to everybody over 50
which raises the question
do they know something we don't sir
well we're looking very closely at their
data as well as our own
this is a tricky situation first let's
point out that just on friday uh cdc's
advisory group and the cdc director
accepted it approved a third shot for
people who have immuno compromise but
that's a separate question what about
the rest of us
again we are looking at this data almost
daily uh yet there is a concern that the
vaccine may start to wane in its
effectiveness over months and delta is a
nasty one for us to try to deal with the
combination of those two means we may
need boosters maybe beginning first with
healthcare providers as well as people
in nursing homes and then gradually
moving forward we have not made that
decision yet because right now the data
we have from the u.s says people who are
vaccinated are fully protected even
against delta when you're talking about
severe disease you're not going to end
up in the hospital if you had that
vaccination and of course the big
message right now this morning is chris
for the people who aren't vaccinated
this is the moment to absolutely get off
the fence and take care of this because
you are a sitting duck for this virus
it's looking for you
but
you must know that there are people who
did get vaccinated
who are seeing and there have been some
studies as you say doesn't indicate
people are going to get
certainly be hospitalized or die but
that the protection from the vaccine is
is waning and as you know some people
have gone and gotten a third booster on
their own in this country uh you know
either lied about it or whatever uh and
you know if you're if you're looking at
what's going on in israel which seems
like a pretty safe and careful country
why shouldn't you say well if they're
doing it i'll do it
well in in fact that is the question
we're asking closely remember israel had
delta hit them sooner than it did us so
in a certain way the timetable we're
looking at is stepped back a bit because
of the spread of this virus that's part
of it but also we're a different kind of
country with different situations we are
getting increasing amount of data from
the u.s
especially the next couple of weeks
we're going to see a lot since delta
really started hitting hard in july and
then we'll make a decision and again i
don't think it's right for people to
jump the gun until we really have the
evidence we're back to where we were a
minute ago chris we're a nation that's
supposed to make decisions based on
evidence let's try to apply that here
too
finally
governor desantis
blames president trump for spreading
kovid by letting so many people with
covid into the country illegally here
was governor desantis on that
whatever variants are around the world
they're coming across that southern
border and so he's not shutting down the
virus he's helping to facilitate it in
our country
you talk about dealing with the science
dealing with facts i'm going to ask you
about that in parts of texas the
positivity right for covet among some of
the illegal migrants coming across the
border is over 10 percent how
responsible are they for spreading for
this wave of covert that is uh sweeping
the country right now
well it's certainly a cause of concern
they have very uh significant masking
requirements there but it is certainly
possible but you know let nobody try to
say that's why the u.s is in trouble the
rate of infection in mexico is actually
lower than it is right now in places
like texas and louisiana and florida i
think that's a bit of a distraction
we've got enough of a problem with our
own citizens who have refused to roll up
their sleeves so maybe that would be a
better thing to focus on if we're trying
to end this that that seemed like it was
not going to get us where we need to be
it's an issue but it's certainly not the
cause of our current dilemma
dr collins thank you thanks for sharing
part of your weekend with us always good
to talk with you sir please come back